well earlier I spoke to Sir David
Nicholson who was the chief executive of
the NHS in England in his now chair of
Worcestershire acute hospitals NHS Trust
I began by asking him for his verdict as
analysis of the NHS his response to the
crisis so far things that the NHS has
put in place the massive increase in
intensive care capacity the development
of cofee three areas in hospitals all of
those things I think the overall you
know thoughts though is those frontline
staff go in for their shifts to care for
these patients without the proper
equipment I mean do you feel you know
looking back to those times of any
personal responsibility do we feel
should we feel that we have let down
those frontline staff who have given
their lives perhaps their the lack of
adequate PPE could be behind some of
those deaths there's no doubt in my mind
as chairman of my own organization I
wouldn't want any of our staff to be
prepared to get into myself but I can
genuinely say that in this organisation
we've managed to keep with some
ingenuity we know that you can't to
carry on but you get the sense we're
going to be able to catch up because
having fallen behind we talked about
that the history of stockpiling now
there's such global demand it doesn't
seem this much of variability globally
to catch up to by the huge amounts of
this equipment that we need I think it
raises a whole set of issues that I
remember talking about when I was the
chief executive about manufacturing
capacity in this country you know over
the last 10 15 20 years we've lost a
huge amount of manufacturing capacity in
this country so we are very dependent on
global supply chains well as
pharmaceuticals or whether it's PPE and
I think we really do need to look our
own capacity to be able to do this in
the circumstances that we find ourselves
I think that's an important point in
terms of the supply at the moment
certainly is for this hospital is
concern
we're getting Justin off at any one time
we probably got three or four days worth
B so as long as the supply chain
continues to do that then I think we'll
be okay but it's the question though
coming down the line of restarting
laughs at the moment about putting more
services off lasting would increase
demand on BPA as well so we need to make
sure but centrally if we've got their
act together
and can deliver it in time and in the
quantities that we need well I suppose
we I mean we had did we have an element
of drift then during those weeks when
the Prime Minister was incapacitated due
to the very virus that's causing the
crisis no I'm very cautious I've said
I'm in the very cautious and we should
complete disaster
we need to make sure that we keep a lock
down and all of that organized but we do
need a sense of hope like anybody else
um you need really ask but we have been
a generals but you need a sense of hope
as to what is the broad pathway that you
need to carry out to enable you to get
to the place where some level of
normality cut comes about and I don't
think yet we've had that narrative from
the government and one of the things
that always every country that's come
out of it some kind of mass testing is
what you do now you don't introduce
testing mass testing by saying you're
going to introduce it you need to take a
lot of action in a detailed way and I'm
interested here today vu course talk
about health care workers do you feel
there has been a bit of a let's
oversight when it comes to those that
work so tirelessly in care homes and the
number of sad deaths we honest
and a taking place there all the focus
seems to be on the NHS the government
figures come from hospitals we don't
really understand or perhaps to
appreciate what is going on in our care
hands on social care you know this is
something you know many people we
included for many years have argued that
and the way we both fund it and we
manages an organised simply isn't in the
right place nothing else comes out of
this a really radical overhaul of Social
Care has to be a big priority